Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist the baskets overflowed on the floor. And there were Valentine parcels and Valentine hampers. Half of the Valentines were really dainty, tasteless things. Many were decoratively printed on satin with fine lace borderings and little golden thread tassels. But at least one fourth were coarse and offensive, too much so for descriptions. Happy Valentine's Day, everybody.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishist 地板上堆满了篮子。到处都是情人节包裹和情人节礼篮。一半的情人节礼物非常精致，但也是毫无品味的俗物。许多礼物是用缎子精美印刷的，带有精致的蕾丝花边边缘和细小的金线流苏。但至少有四分之一是粗俗且冒犯人的，简直难以形容。大家情人节快乐。
Those are the words of a post office clerk who is remembering the late Victorian period, which is in some ways the heyday, I would say, of Valentine's Day. Tom, are you a great enthusiast for Valentine's Day? Not normally. And the simple reason for that is that Sadie, my beloved wife, is very, very hostile to displays of commercialised sentimentality. And so she gets very cross if I give her a Valentine's Day card or do anything like that.
这是某位邮局职员对维多利亚时代晚期的回忆，在某种程度上，可以说那是情人节的鼎盛时期。汤姆，你是一个狂热的情人节爱好者吗？通常不是。原因很简单，我深爱的妻子萨迪非常非常反感商业化的情感宣泄。所以如果我送她情人节贺卡或做类似的事情，她会非常生气。
Although, excitingly, I am taking her out tonight. Oh, that's nice. So that's good. However, I think, I mean, you know, being lovely on Valentine's Day is all well and good. But you were saying in that that a quarter of the cards were coarse and offensive. Well, I have some splendidly offensive Valentine's cards to come in the second half of this episode. So don't go away if you want to hear really offensive Valentine's Day messages. And I can absolutely vouch for that because you've been texting them to me, some of them.
不过，令人兴奋的是，我今晚要带她出去。哦，那挺好的。那很不错。不过，我想，你知道的，在情人节表现得可爱固然很好。但你刚才说，有四分之一的卡片是粗俗且冒犯人的。好吧，在本集的后半部分，我将带来一些精彩绝伦、极具冒犯性的情人节卡片。所以，如果你想听真正冒犯的情人节祝福，千万不要走开。我绝对可以担保，因为其中有些是你发短信发给我的。
And they really are coarse and offensive. So that is something definitely to look forward to. That gives you a sense of the kind of banter that we do off when we're not recording. Sending each other Victorian ditties. So, but Dominic, Valentine's Day, why are we celebrating it? That's the kind of the big question, isn't it? I don't know, because basically all the questions we had on Twitter and on the Discord for Restless History Club members,
而且它们确实粗俗又冒犯。所以这绝对是值得期待的。这让你感受到了我们在不录音时开的那种玩笑。互相发送维多利亚时期的打油诗。那么，多米尼克，情人节，我们为什么要庆祝它？这算是那个最大的问题，对吧？我不知道，因为基本上我们在推特以及针对“历史的余烬俱乐部”成员的Discord上收到的所有问题，
they sort of came from the same, well, they came at it at the same angle that people approach Christmas and Easter and things, didn't they? Sort of, is it a pagan festival that has been crudely taken over by the by the catholic church or is it a hallmark holiday that has been invented by marketing men in tuscaloosa the whole the whole thing is unbelievably complicated yeah and i reckon it's more complicated than christmas or easter because at least complicated well the thing is with christmas and easter it reckon it's more complicated than Christmas or Easter. More complicated. Well, the thing is, with Christmas and Easter, it's pretty clear why they're happening. The birth of Jesus, the resurrection of Jesus, these are key events in the life of the central figure in Christianity.
它们某种程度上都来自同一个，嗯，它们切入的角度和人们对待圣诞节、复活节等节日的方式如出一辙，不是吗？比如说，这到底是被天主教节日生搬硬套接管的异教节日，还是由塔斯卡卢萨的营销人员发明的商业噱头？整件事情复杂得难以置信。是的，而且我认为它比圣诞节或复活节还要复杂，因为至少……复杂的……好吧，圣诞节和复活节的问题在于，我认为它比圣诞节或复活节更复杂。更复杂。好吧，圣诞节和复活节的问题在于，它们的由来相当清晰。耶稣的诞生，耶稣的复活，这些是基督教核心人物生平中的关键事件。
But with Valentine, it's a lot more complicated because who is St. Valentine? How many Valentines were there? When was he martyred? Was he martyred? Did he exist? What happened to him? I hope you're going to answer those questions because I don't know the answers. So the problem is I don't think that there are any absolute, historically guaranteed answers to this.
但对于瓦伦丁来说，事情要复杂得多，因为圣瓦伦丁究竟是谁？曾经有过多少个瓦伦丁？他是何时殉道的？他殉道了吗？他真的存在过吗？他后来怎么了？我希望你能回答这些问题，因为我并不知道答案。所以问题在于，我认为并没有任何绝对的、历史上有保证的答案。
So there are multiple St. Valentines. There's not one canonical Valentine. Okay. So in the Roman martyrology, which is the current kind of compendium of people who were martyred, you get at Rome on the Via Flaminia by the Milvian Bridge, St. Valentine Martyr. So the Via Flaminia is the road that leads from Rome to the Adriatic,
所以有多个圣瓦伦丁。并不存在一个正统的、唯一的瓦伦丁。好吧。在罗马殉道录中，也就是当前关于殉道者的编纂名录中，你会看到在罗马弗拉米尼亚大道（Via Flaminia）靠近米尔维安桥（Milvian Bridge）的地方，有圣瓦伦丁殉道者。所以弗拉米尼亚大道是从罗马通往亚得里亚海的道路，
kind of over the Apennines. Milvian Bridge will be familiar to all fans of Constantine. That's where he won his great victory. So St. Valentine, the problem is there was also another Valentine who was the Bishop of Turney, which is a place 60 miles north of Rome. And basically he has the same name. He was a martyr. The Roman martyrology is now saying that these are the same people.
某种程度上穿过亚平宁山脉。米尔维安桥对于君士坦丁的所有粉丝来说都会很熟悉。那是他赢得伟大胜利的地方。所以圣瓦伦丁，问题在于，还有另一个瓦伦丁，他是特尔尼（Turney）的主教，特尔尼是罗马以北60英里处的一个地方。基本上他有着相同的名字。他也是个殉道者。罗马殉道录现在宣称这其实是同一个人。
But they're not. Well, we don't know. We don't know. I mean, maybe they are, maybe they're not. But I mean, if they've got the same date, the same name, the assumption usually is that they're the same person. But then adding to the complication, there's another Valentine who was the Bishop of Genoa, whose feast day is the second of may and that is important because that comes in later for the question of how and why valentine's valentine comes to be associated with romance so it's it's an absolute kind of snarl and not um so probably there is a valentine there was a valentine he was martyred um his relics were preserved but the stories that then start to accumulate how historically accurate these are i you know very very hard to say but almost certainly they're not accurate i would i would guess um so when is he martyred uh 14th february so that's
但他们并不是。好吧，我们不知道。我们不知道。我的意思是，也许他们是，也许不是。但我的意思是，如果他们有相同的日期、相同的名字，通常的假设就是他们是同一个人。但为了增加复杂性，还有另一个瓦伦丁，他是热那亚的主教，他的瞻礼日是5月2日，这很重要，因为这后来涉及到了瓦伦丁是如何以及为什么与浪漫联系在一起的问题。所以这是一个绝对剪不断理还乱的结，不，嗯，所以可能确实有一个瓦伦丁，曾有过一个瓦伦丁，他殉道了，嗯，他的遗物被保存了下来，但随后开始积累起来的那些故事，这些故事在历史上有多少准确性，我（你知道的）非常非常难以置信，但几乎可以肯定它们并不准确，我猜想，嗯，那么他是何时殉道的？呃，2月14日，所以这就是——
yeah that's why we have his feast day on the 14th of fe. And late traditions say that it was in the reign of Claudius, the Emperor Claudius. All right. So pretty early. Really? Well, no, because it doesn't fit in historically with the early Emperor Claudius, the stutterer, the hero of. There's a later Emperor Claudius, right?
是的，这就是为什么我们将他的瞻礼日定在2月14日。而后期的传统则称，那是在克劳狄乌斯统治时期，即克劳狄乌斯皇帝在位期间。好吧。所以时间相当早。真的吗？嗯，不对，因为这在历史上与早期的克劳狄乌斯皇帝不符，那个口吃者，那个……的英雄。还有一个后来的克劳狄乌斯皇帝，对吧？
There is. In the third century? I don't know, fourth century? Claudius Gothicus. So when's he? Roughly. So he is 268 to 70 he he reigns so he is a product of the third century um implosion of of the roman empire and he's one of those kind of breed of rugged tough novak djokovic type um emperors from the balkans who uh he's been deported from australia and yeah that
确实有。在公元三世纪？我不知道，四世纪？哥特克劳狄乌斯（Claudius Gothicus）。那他是哪个时期的？大致来说。所以他在公元268年到270年在位，所以他是公元三世纪罗马帝国崩溃的产物，他是那种来自巴尔干地区的粗犷、强悍、诺瓦克·德约科维奇式的皇帝之一，他曾被从澳大利亚驱逐出境，诸如此类。
kind of thing well so he he's he's very he's um he's rough he's tough uh there's a story that he punched a horse in the mouth knocked out all his teeth so he'd be sacked as a primary school teacher if he did that wouldn't he absolutely would yeah he'd get in trouble if he was a footballer um no it wasn't it was a cat wasn get in trouble if he was a footballer. No, it wasn't. It was a cat, wasn't it?
嗯，所以他，他非常，他，他很粗鲁，很强悍，有一个故事说他一拳打在马嘴上，把马的牙齿全打掉了。如果他那样做的话，他会被小学开除的，不是吗？绝对会的，是的，如果他是个足球运动员，他会惹上麻烦的。不，不是的，那是一只猫，不是——如果他是个足球运动员，他会惹上麻烦的。不，不是的。那是一只猫，对吧？
He was. Yeah. The Premier League footballer was a cat. I didn't think we'd get here in a session of Valentine's Day, but I'm glad we have. Yeah. So he's, so this,
确实是。是的。英超足球运动员是一只猫。我没想到我们在一个讨论情人节的节目里会聊到这个，但我很高兴我们聊了。是的。所以他，所以这个，
this Claudius is the second one is very keen on punching out teeth. So there's, there's a story that he, he punched a horse in the mouth and all the horse's teeth went flying. Okay. And then he was in a wrestling match and his opponent reached out and grabbed him by the bollocks. And so predictably, Claudius smashed him in the face and knocked out all his teeth. So that's very much his party trick. And when the emperor is in the process of implosion, it's obviously the kind of talents that you need yeah so he ends up becoming emperor and he's a very
这个克劳狄乌斯是第二位，非常热衷于打掉别人的牙齿。所以，有一个故事说他一拳打在马嘴上，马的牙齿全都飞了出来。好吧。然后他在一次摔跤比赛中，对手伸手抓住了他的蛋蛋。所以不出所料，克劳狄乌斯狠狠地砸向对方的脸，打掉了他所有的牙齿。所以这非常符合他的拿手好戏。当帝国正处于崩溃的过程中时，这显然是你所需要的那种才能。所以他最终成为了皇帝，而且他是一个非常
good emperor he's a strong military leader he defeats the alamani he defeats the goths so that's why he gets his the name gothicus um and then he dies of um plague so one of the uh one of the horrendous plagues that sweeps over the roman empire in the third century um and so possibly it's this claudius but the problem is that as you will gather from the synopsis i've given he's not actually around in rome very much to go around martyring people but he's he's off punching he doesn't he doesn't see horses in the teeth on the frontier he doesn't sound like a friend of romance right i mean no he's not the kind of man who'd be immortalized in a middle american greetings card so well no but but but the thing is that he's martyring valentine yeah yeah no so the so the stories are kind of these these these are increasingly medieval legends that um
好的皇帝，他是一个强悍的军事领袖，他击败了阿拉曼尼人，击败了哥特人，所以这就是他为什么被称为“哥特克劳狄乌斯”的原因，然后他死于瘟疫——也就是席卷公元三世纪罗马帝国的那些可怕瘟疫之一。所以可能就是这个克劳狄乌斯，但问题是，正如你从我给出的简介中了解到的那样，他其实并不经常在罗马到处把人抓去殉道。他在外面挥拳头，他不在前线看马的牙齿。他听起来不像是浪漫的朋友，对吧？我的意思是，不，他不是那种会被中西部美式贺卡永垂不朽的人，所以，
valentine is a christian at a time when it's illegal to be a christian he is um he gets arrested by a judge. He then converts the judge. Further stories say that the daughter of the judge fell in love with him and that he teaches her to love Jesus and all this kind of stuff. And then Claudius comes in, also very fond of Valentine, tries to persuade Valentine to give up his Christianity, ends up having him martyred. And the story is he gets beaten to death with clubs so you've got all these kind of various folkloric yeah mythic um elements of the story that get elaborated over the middle ages and then once you start to get the association with romance that will come to then they you start to get kind of daughters of judges and
好吧，不，但关键是他在把瓦伦丁殉道。是的，是的，所以这些故事基本上是越来越多的中世纪传说，说瓦伦丁是一个基督徒，当时信仰基督教是违法的，他，他被一个法官逮捕了。然后他感化了那个法官。进一步的故事还说，法官的女儿爱上了他，他教导她去爱耶稣诸如此类的事情。然后克劳狄乌斯登场了，他也非常喜欢瓦伦丁，试图说服瓦伦丁放弃基督教信仰，最终下令将他殉道。传说是他被棍棒殴打至死。所以你拥有了所有这些各种各样的民俗的、神话的元素，这些元素在整个中世纪不断被丰富和润色，一旦你开始将它与浪漫联系起来——这将在后文发生——你就会发现法官的女儿和皇帝的女儿全都被塞进了这个故事里。但在其最初的形式中，这个故事中绝对没有任何色情或浪漫的成分，除非你觉得打马的脸很浪漫。这里绝对没有任何、绝对没有任何浪漫的东西。但是，汤姆，在罗马历法的这个时期，难道没有一个现存的狂欢节吗？这就是“牧神节”（Lupercalia）时期吗？我没记错吧？你没记错。
daughters of emperors all get fed into the story. But in its initial form, there's nothing erotic or romantic in this story at all, unless you find punching horses in the face. There is absolutely nothing, nothing romantic at all. But is there not an existing festival around this time in the Roman calendar, Tom? Is this the time of the Lupercalia? Have I got that right? You have.
所以吉姆·瓦凯特（Jim Wackett）就此向我们提问：情人节是一个真正的异教罗马节日——牧神节——被基督教化并与圣人日结合的例子吗？是的。所以这相当于那种认为圣诞节就是换了个名字的农神节的观点。完全正确。好吧，那我来描述一下牧神节期间发生了什么，你可以看看你觉得怎么样。所以，牧神节大约是在二月中旬庆祝的——也就是13日、14日、15日那个时期。所以二月十四日正好处于这个时期的正中央。它在帕拉蒂尼山（Palatine）周边举行，一直延伸到古罗马广场。
So we've got a question on that from Jim Wackett. Is Valentine's Day a genuine example of a pagan Roman festival, the Lupercalia, that was Christianized and associated with the Saints' Day? Yeah. So this is the equivalent to the idea that Christmas is, you know, the Saturnalia with a different name. Exactly. Well, so I will describe what went on with the lupicalia and you can see see what you think um so so the lupicalia was celebrated um kind of in the middle of february so 13th 14th 15th that kind of period so you've got you have got the 14th of february kind of bang in the middle of that um it took place around the Palatine running into the forum.
所以帕拉蒂尼山是罗马最终成为皇家宫殿的那座山丘。嗯，当然就是皇宫所在地。但这是一个非常古老的节日。而且，它并不是那种会产生大量贺卡的节日。所以你必须做的是，你通过献祭几只山羊和一只狗来庆祝这个节日。
So the Palatine is the hill in Rome that ends up becoming the Imperial. Yeah. Well, the palace, obviously. But it's a very ancient festival. And it's, well, it's not the kind of festival that would generate, I think, a huge number of Hallmark cards. So what you have to do, you mark the festival by offering up various goats and a dog in sacrifice.
然后你取它们的血。看哪，各位，没有人介意献祭山羊，对吧？但只要一提到狗，许多听众就会翻白眼，说：怎么又是死狗。我想人们其实也挺喜欢山羊的。是的，我想是的，我觉得我们对山羊的感情没那么深，我们没那么感伤。我同意，是的，我同意，我同意。不过抱歉，我扯远了，我们来聊聊牧神节吧。
And you take their blood. See, everybody, no one minds the sacrifice of goats, do they? But as soon as you mention the dog, a lot of listeners will be rolling their eyes and saying, dead dogs again. I think people quite like goats as well. they yeah i think so i think we're less affection we're less sentimental i agree yes i agree i agree but anyway sorry i've i've sidetracked you let's talk about the loop calia yeah so so you you you these dead goats yeah there's dead dog you mix the blood you wipe it on the brows of two small boys, and then you immediately wipe it clean again. And this is the key thing. The boys then have to burst out into wild laughter.
所以，那些死山羊，还有死狗，你把它们的血混在一起，涂在两个小男孩的额头上，然后立刻又把它们擦干净。这才是关键所在。接着，这些男孩必须爆发出狂野的笑声。如果这不管用，他们就得把整个过程从头到尾再做一遍。哇。所以这些男孩压力好大啊。是的。好吧，如果你是一只山羊或是一只狗，显然，显然你心里有数，而且你排着队以防男孩们不笑，这里面风险很大。无论如何，事情就是这样发生的，然后接下来发生的是，女人们基本上会脱掉衣服，赤裸上身，聚集在帕拉蒂尼山的山麓周围。
And if that doesn't work, then they have to do the whole thing over again. Wow. So there's a lot of pressure on those boys. Yeah. Well, if you're a goat or a dog, obviously, obviously you know and you're lined up in case the boys don't laugh there's a lot at stake anyway so that happens and then what happens is women will basically kind of strip themselves uh will go topless and they'll all gather around the kind of the spurs of the hill of the palatine yeah and the the men who are taking part in the Lupercalia will strip right, right down to kind of very, very skimpy thongs.
而参加牧神节的男人们则会脱得精光，只剩下非常非常清凉的皮制丁字裤。然后他们开始绕着帕拉蒂尼山的山麓奔跑。当他们跑过时，手里会拿着一根山羊皮条，用山羊皮条抽打那些赤裸上身的女性。这是为了遵从曾给罗马人的一则神谕，神谕说圣洁的山羊必须进入意大利的母亲们体内。所以显然山羊进入意大利母亲体内有各种各样的方式。这在某种程度上是最不具有侵入性、
And they will then start running round the spurs of the Palatine. Yeah. And as they go by, they will be carrying a kind of goat thong and they will whip the bare-breasted women with the goat thong. And this is in obedience to an oracle that had been given to the Romans where it said the sacred goat must enter the mothers of Italy. So obviously there are various ways in which a sacred goat could enter the mothers of Italy. This is in a way the least intrusive
最端庄的方式。这是最端庄的做法，也是一种用来……制止死产的方法。这管用吗？我猜……好吧，是的，管用，不，确实管用，确实管用。所以这就是为什么女性会主动献身接受鞭笞——她们的胸部会被山羊皮条狠狠地抽打，然后她们就会——你知道的，怀孕就会起效。所以就是这样，这就是牧神节。其实你的书《卢比孔河》（Rubicon）里对此有段精彩的描述，对吧？马克·安东尼也这么干过，对吧？
the most decorous this is the most decorous way of doing it and it's a way of of um stopping um stillbirths does it work um i'm guessing well yes it does no it does it does and so this is why uh women offer themselves up to the lash uh they get you know get smacked over the breasts with the the goat thong and then they they all you know pregnancies work so so there you go so so that's the lupicalia there's a brilliant description of this actually in your book rubicon isn't it mark anthony do it yeah mark so mark anthony does it yes uh and um that's the one where he ends up offering caesar the crown yeah so that's why it's yes that's sort of running through the streets isn't he yeah mark anthony's very much the kind of guy who would enjoy running around rome in a skimpy loincloth
马克·安东尼确实这么干过，是的，这就是他最后把王冠献给凯撒的那次。所以这就是为什么，是的，他在街头奔跑，对吧？马克·安东尼非常喜欢那种穿着清凉的腰布、在罗马街头奔跑，
yeah whipping whipping women over their breasts with a goat thong the sort of bad behavior of the bullying clubs of history is a definite theme of this podcast and that is absolutely on trend isn't it well so so you so this idea that there's an obvious line of descent from the Lupercalia to St. Valentine's Day, it's not obvious. No, it's not. And actually, if a Roman were transplanted into the 21st century, you said, this is what Lupercalia has become.
用山羊皮条抽打女性胸部的家伙。历史上这种恃强凌弱的帮派的不良行为绝对是这个播客的一个主题，这完全赶上潮流了，不是吗？嗯，所以，你，所以这种认为从牧神节到情人节存在一条清晰演变脉络的想法，其实并不明显。不，一点也不明显。事实上，如果一个古罗马人被空投到21世纪，你对他说：“这就是牧神节演变来的样子。”
Yes. Get yourself down to Clinton Gardens. Very disappointing. I very disappointing immensely disappointed very dull the lupicala is a very popular ceremony it has very very you know deep roots in the roman past and it's not until right at the end of the fifth century that it it gets banned it's bad it's actually banned it doesn't die out it's banned by a pope called galatius who's who's you know he objects to it um so i think it's kind of uh 496 or something like that it gets banned by a Pope called Galatius who's, you know, he objects to it. So I think it's kind of 496 or something like that.
是的。快去克林顿花园（Clinton Gardens）看看吧。非常令人失望。我非常失望，极其失望，非常无聊。牧神节是一个非常受欢迎的仪式，它在罗马的过去中有着非常非常深厚的根源，直到五世纪末，它才被禁止。它被禁止了。它其实是被禁止的，它并没有消亡，而是被一位名叫格拉修斯（Galatius）的教皇下令禁止的，他对此表示反对……所以我想大约是在公元496年左右，它被一位名叫格拉修斯、对此表示反对的教皇所禁止。所以我想大约是在公元496年左右，
It gets banned by him. So the question then is, well, how and why does Valentine come to be associated with romance? So you said that a lot of festivals, you know, we assume that they're American. Yeah. The current thinking is that actually Valentine's Day is probably English. Oh, that's nice. Yeah. That's good. And it seems to have emerged against the backdrop of the great literary revolution at the end of the 14th century.
它被教皇禁止了。那么问题来了，瓦伦丁究竟是如何以及为什么与浪漫联系在一起的呢？所以你刚才说很多节日，我们都想当然地认为它们是美国的。对吧？目前的普遍看法是，实际上情人节很可能是英国的。哦，那挺好的。是的。那很不错。它似乎是在14世纪末伟大的文学革命背景下浮现出来的。
With Chaucer. Chaucer and John Gower and all kinds of people like that. And the first kind of mention that we get in English poetry is in a poem by Chaucer called The Parliament of Fowls. Yeah. Fan of The Parliament of Fowls? I've seen bits of it on the internet. Seen the film. Yeah, seen the film yeah it's in the cartoon it's great now tell me about the parliament of fouls tom you know i know nothing about it at all okay so the parliament of fouls is an interesting poem yeah
伴随着乔叟（Chaucer）。乔叟、约翰·戈尔（John Gower）以及诸如此类的各种人物。我们在英国诗歌中听到的首次提及，是在乔叟的一首名为《百鸟会》（The Parliament of Fowls）的诗中。是的。你是《百鸟会》的粉丝吗？我在互联网上看过一些片段。看过电影。对，看过电影，对，在动画片里，太棒了。现在跟我讲讲《百鸟会》吧，汤姆，你知道我对它一无所知。好吧，所以《百鸟会》是一首有趣的诗，
um because it's the first uh poem that actually mentions the word election in the sense that we use it now of kind of choosing right you know choosing someone to to represent you politically. Did election have a previous meaning? Yeah. What does it mean? Well you know the the election of you know it's are you part of the elect that kind of thing. Oh I see okay okay okay so this means an election as in a kind of democratic. An election as in the general election that we yeah we'd have now um and so the plot of it is that Chaucer is reading a book by Cicero, The Dream of Scipio, and he falls asleep. Scipio appears to him, leads him up through the celestial spheres,
嗯，因为它第一首真正提到“选举”（election）这个词的诗，这里的含义是我们现在所用的那种选择的含义——对吧——选择某人来代表你的政治意愿。选举之前有别的含义吗？有的。是什么意思？嗯，你知道的，挑选某人的选举——也就是说，你是被神拣选的人那类意思。哦，我明白了，好吧，好吧，所以这意味着像某种民主意义上的选举。像我们现在要举行的大选那样的选举，嗯，所以它的情节是乔叟在读西塞罗的一本书《西塞罗之梦》（The Dream of Scipio），然后他睡着了。西塞罗出现在他面前，带领他穿过天球，
and he finds himself in the Temple of Venus, and he walks through the Temple of Venus, and it's very dark, and there are images of unhappy lovers and then he comes out into this um this kind of bright meadow a hill of flowers and all the birds are there and it's their parliament and this parliament shows the lords you know so the top birds yeah but also the commons so it's the first representation in poetry of what would become the parliamentary system and the backdrop to this is the you know that's kind of the wave of weird parliaments that you get at the end of the 14th century
然后他发现自己置身于维纳斯神庙中，他穿过维纳斯神庙，里面非常昏暗，到处都是不幸恋人的雕像，接着他走出来，来到了这个……嗯，这个明亮的原野、花的山丘上，所有的鸟儿都在那里，这就是它们的议会。这个议会展示了领主们（也就是顶级的鸟儿们），但也展示了平民。所以这是诗歌中对日后将成为议会系统的雏形的首次描绘。而这背后的背景是14世纪末期出现的各种奇奇怪怪的议会浪潮，
yeah kind of the good parliament and the the bad parliament and all those kind of various parliaments there must be other parliaments than are good and bad. Anyway, so among all this, what's happening in this parliament is that the birds are choosing their mates. Mates as in romantic others rather than mates. And you get this verse. For this was on St. Valentine's Day when every fowl cometh there to choose his make
比如“良善议会”和“残酷议会”以及所有那些形形色色的议会。除了好议会和坏议会之外，肯定还有别的议会。无论如何，在这一切之中，这个议会里正在发生的事情是鸟儿们在挑选它们的伴侣。这里的伴侣是指浪漫意义上的另一半，而不是哥们儿。然后你就会读到这节诗：因为那是圣瓦伦丁节，当每只鸟儿都来到那里，去挑选它的伴侣，
of every kind that men think may and that's a huger noise can they make that earth and air and tree and every lake so full was that underneath was their space for me to stand so full was all the place i liked that uh sam gamgee rendition that you gave initially thank you thank you thank you very yeah, I mean, so I think you do want to imagine these birds in a kind of a shire, an idyllic landscape, green hills, all that kind of stuff. And the implication of this is that it's the time of year when, you know, spring is coming, the end of winter, thoughts turn to romance. And so that, I think, is why it's Valentine is associated with, you know, it's the time of year. It's the beginning of spring. It's the sap rising, all that kind of stuff. But again, the question is, why is Chaucer fixing on Valentine's Day?
各种鸟儿应有尽有，人们认为它们可以……它们能发出比大地、天空、树木和每一片湖泊还要巨大的喧闹声，那个地方是如此拥挤，以至于下方都没有我落脚的空间了，整个地方都是如此。我挺喜欢你刚才那种山姆·怀斯（Sam Gamgee）式的朗诵。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，非常……是的，我的意思是，所以我觉得你确实会想要把这些鸟儿想象成生活在一个夏尔那样的地方，一个田园诗般的风景中，绿色的山丘，所有那些类型的景色。而这背后的暗示是，这是一年中的那个时候，你知道，春天来临了，冬天的结束，人们的思想转向了浪漫。所以我想，这就是为什么瓦伦丁会与……你知道的，因为这是一年中的这个时候。这是春天的开始。树液开始上升，所有类似的事情。但同样的问题是，为什么乔叟要锁定情人节呢？
And it's not just Chaucer who's doing this. So John Gower, who is Moral Gower, Chaucer calls him um who's another poet writes in english but also writes in latin writes in french and in one of these french poems gower um describes saint valentine greater than any emperor holding a parliament and assembly of all the birds who come on his day where the female takes her mate in proper love so again this kind of weird thing what what you know what is going on here and these guys one of them is not copying the other they're both doing it coincidentally do you think or well gower and chaucer are friends so there is debate about this yeah about who comes
不仅乔叟在这样做。所以约翰·戈尔——乔叟称他为“道德的戈尔”——他也是另一位用英语写作、但也用拉丁语和法语写作的诗人。在其中一首法语诗中，戈尔将圣瓦伦丁描述得比任何皇帝还要伟大，他主持着所有鸟儿的议会和集会，鸟儿们在他的节日里到来，雌鸟在真爱中挑选她的伴侣。所以再次出现了这种奇怪的事情：这到底是怎么回事？而这两个家伙，其中一个并不是在抄袭另一个，他们是巧合地同时这样做的吗？还是说——嗯，戈尔和乔叟是朋友，所以关于这一点是有争论的，关于谁先开始，
first and it's and the precise dating of chaucer's poem is important because one of the theories about what's going on here and why it's being written is that it marks the treaty of marriage that is being signed between Richard II and Anne of Bohemia, which takes place in 1381. But here is the twist. Is it on the 14th of February, Dominic? Or is it on the 2nd of May, which you'll remember. Was another Valentine's Day. Was the feast day of the Valentine who is the Bishop of Genoa. Gosh, the stakes are high on this, Tom. Well, there's no answer.
而且乔叟这首诗的确切创作日期很重要，因为关于这里到底发生了什么以及为什么要写这首诗的理论之一是，它标志着理查二世与波希米亚的安妮于1381年签署的婚姻条约。但这里有个转折。这是在2月14日吗，多米尼克？还是在5月2日？你可能还记得。那是另一个情人节。那是热那亚主教瓦伦丁的瞻礼日。天哪，这赌注可真高啊，汤姆。好吧，没有答案。
There's no answer. I mean, we don't know is the answer. But isn't this also, is the backdrop to all this, that it's the age of courtly love and sort of chivalric romances? And so the whole business about choosing a mate and the sort of, you imagine the sort of almost like the ritualistic dances or something at the courts. This is part of that, isn't it?
没有答案。我的意思是，答案是我们不知道。但这难道不是也因为——这一切的背景是，这是一个宫廷之爱和骑士传奇的时代？所以关于选择伴侣的整件事情，以及那种——你可以想象宫廷里那种几乎像某种仪式化的舞蹈之类的东西。这是其中的一部分，对吧？
It absolutely is. So all that language of courtly love, I mean, Chaucer is very keen on that, translating the romance of the rose, all that kind of stuff, you know, the theory and myths and all that kind of, you know, Lancelot and Guinevere, all that kind of thing. And it just seems to be part of the language of the English court at this period. Yeah. And over the course of the 15th century, so Richard II gets toppled, henry the fourth who replaces him and then friend of the show henry the fifth yeah and in the reign of henry the fifth it really starts to pick up so the very first valentine that we have surviving so you know a poem written to someone asking them
绝对是的。所以所有那些宫廷之爱的语言——我的意思是乔叟非常热衷于此，翻译《玫瑰传奇》（The Romance of the Rose）之类的所有东西，你知道的，宫廷爱恋的理论和神话，兰斯洛特和吉尼维尔，所有那类事情。这似乎就是当时英国宫廷语言的一部分。是的。而在15世纪的进程中——所以理查二世被推翻了，取而代之的是亨利四世，然后是本节目的好朋友亨利五世——在亨利五世统治时期，这个习俗真的开始流行起来了。所以我们现存最早的情人节——你知道的，写给某人请求他们成为自己情人节伴侣的诗——是由奥尔良公爵查理（Charles, Duke of Orléans）写的。他在阿金库尔战役中被俘，被带回英国并锁在塔楼里，他在塔楼里关了漫长的好多年，
to be their valentine is by charles the duke of orleans who was captured at agincourt who gets brought back to england and locked up in the tower and he's there in the tower for kind of years and years and years um and and he writes um to his wife i am sick of love my very gentle valentine je suis déjà d'amour tannay matre douce valentine so he calls her his Valentine. So that expression, be my Valentine, people are using it in the 15th century. My very sweet Valentine. But when he's calling her his Valentine, does he mean, you know, you are the spirit of St. Valentine? Or has the word Valentine taken on this kind of romantic meaning at that point? I mean, obviously, presumably the latter.
然后他写信给他的妻子：“我为爱病倒了，我非常温柔的情人”（Je suis déjà d'amour tannay / Ma très douce Valentin）。所以他称她为他的情人节（Valentine）。所以“成为我的情人节”这个表达，人们在15世纪就已经在使用了。我非常甜美的情人。但当他称她为他的情人节时，他的意思是——你知道的，“你是圣瓦伦丁的精神化身”？还是说“情人节”这个词在当时已经变成了具有浪漫色彩的含义？我的意思是，显然，大概是后者吧。
I think the latter, yeah. And so the process by which, you know, what it is that joins Chaucer and Gower's poems in the English court to Charles, Duke of Orléans coming up with this. I mean, he's in England. He's at the English court. So presumably that's where he's picked it up. And you then get John Lydgate, who's a poet from the reign of Henry V and after.
我认为是后者，是的。所以，将乔叟和戈尔在英国宫廷的诗歌与奥尔良公爵查理提出这一说法的过程串联起来的东西……我的意思是，他在英国。他在英国宫廷。所以大概他就是在那里学到的。然后你又有了约翰·利德门（John Lydgate），他是亨利五世统治时期及之后的诗人。
And he's writing in honor of Queen Catherine. Yeah, Catherine of Valois. Who's married Henry V and been left widowed and will go on to marry Owen Tudor. And he again refers to valentine's day to look and search cupid's calendar and choose their choice by great affection so there you've got the idea of of a valentine is someone that you choose so like a knight choosing his lady yeah so on valentine's day you choose your valentine um and by the end towards the end of the 15th century you've got the past and letters past letters are have i think three references to people becoming valentines so um marjorie
他为凯瑟琳王后（Queen Catherine）写诗歌功颂德。是的，瓦卢瓦的凯瑟琳。她嫁给了亨利五世，后来守寡，并最终嫁给了欧文·都铎（Owen Tudor）。他又一次提到了情人节：“去查阅和搜寻丘比特的历法，凭着深厚的情感选择他们的所爱”。所以在这里你有了这样的概念：情人节就是你选择的人，就像骑士选择他的淑女一样。是的，所以在情人节这天，你选择你的情人；
bruise writing to her future husband calls him my right well beloved valentine and the idea is also then starts to pick up through into the 16th century that you send tokens to your valentine but these are people you're already you're already betrothed or married to, right? These are not just random people that you've got your eye on kind of thing. Well, I don't think there's a hard and fast rule because this is an evolving tradition. Yeah. So the fact that the feast day of Valentine gets abolished by Edward VI, with you know the reformation kicks in so saint's day's in for dig but valentine's day is is kept as the expression of an evolving tradition where there are kind of various possibilities so by the 17th century yeah
到了15世纪末期，你有了《帕斯顿书信》（Paston Letters）。《帕斯顿书信》中我认为有三处提及人们成为情人节伴侣的事情，比如玛乔丽·布鲁斯（Marjorie Brews）写给她未来丈夫的信中，称他为“我真正深心情人节伴侣”。这种想法在16世纪也开始流行开来，即你向你的情人节伴侣发送信物，但这些人是你已经订婚或结婚的人，对吧？这些不只是你随随便便看中的路人甲，对吧？嗯，我认为并没有硬性的规则，因为这是一个不断演变的传统。是的。所以尽管爱德华六世废除了圣瓦伦丁的瞻礼日——随着宗教改革的到来，圣人日失宠了——但情人节作为不断演变传统的一种表现形式被保留了下来，其中存在各种可能性。所以在17世纪，
there are various ways in which you can choose a valentine so there's the one that we would understand that you you know there's a beautiful woman uh or indeed beautiful man and you um you know you you send the equivalent of a card a valentine card yeah so what someone who does that is um the future james ii the duke of york who um sees lady Frances Stewart who is reputedly the most beautiful of all the uh the women at Charles II's court um becomes the model for Britannia um and he gives her a jewel worth 800 pounds as a valentine that's a lot of money in modern times I mean it is so that's better than a card then there's there's uh this idea that you can um that you you you get your valentine by lot and so there are kind of various jokes made throughout the 17th century
有各种各样的方式可以选择一个情人节伴侣。所以有一种是我们能够理解的，即有一个美丽的女子——或者确实是一个美男子——然后你……你知道的，你发送相当于卡片的东西，也就是情人节贺卡。这样做的人之一，就是未来的詹姆斯二世（即当时的约克公爵），他看中了弗朗西斯·斯图尔特小姐（Lady Frances Stewart），她据说是查理二世宫廷里所有女性中最美的一位，后来成为了“不列颠尼亚”形象的模特，他送了她价值800英镑的珠宝作为情人节礼物。在现代这可是一大笔钱。我的意思是，确实是的。所以这比一张卡片要好。然后还有这样一种观点：你可以通过抽签的方式来决定你的情人节伴侣。所以在整个17世纪，人们开过各种各样的玩笑，说这才是挑选公职人员的正确方式。
that this is how um public officials should be chosen all right so people say choose a public official like a valentine's yeah yeah interesting yeah yeah and then the third one is so this is a report from a dutch visitor who comes to england in um 60 63 it is customary alike for married as for unmarried people that the first person one meets in the morning that is if one is a man the first woman or girl becomes one's valentine he asks her name which he takes down and carries on a long strip of paper in his hat band in the same way the woman or girl wears his name on her bodice and then you get presents from them so um it's a kind of nice idea that this is all done at completely at random that's not that isn't i like that idea
好吧，所以人们说：像选情人节伴侣一样去选一个公职人员。是的，是的，有趣，是的。然后第三种是——这是一位在16世纪63年来到英国的荷兰游客的记录：“无论是已婚还是未婚的人，习俗都是这样的：早晨遇到的第一个人——如果是个男的，遇到的第一个女人或女孩——就会成为他的情人节伴侣。他会问她的名字，记下来，并写在一长条纸上别在帽子带上。同样地，女人或女孩也会把他的名字戴在胸衣上。”然后你会从他们那里收到礼物。所以……这是一个很好的想法，这一切完全是随机完成的，这不是……那不是——我喜欢这个想法。
but of course it's quite high risk yes and the dutch visitor goes on to say that actually this gets kind of planned in advance yeah so you know the girl will be lurking around the corner waiting for the boy to run past or whatever oh that's good i like that so you i mean you you have the sense of this this tradition emerging nobody quite knows how but it's associated with the feast day of valentine yeah and then valentine becomes associated with all the you know this idea that you you choose a valentine and that it's romantic well that at this point you see it's quite it is quite romantic and it's not commercialized is it there's no because how could it be because there's no infrastructure of sort of commercialism that could really exploit it i mean that's that's
但当然，这风险相当高。是的。这位荷兰游客接着说，实际上这一切都是事先计划好的。是的，你知道的，女孩会潜伏在角落里等待男孩跑过，诸如此类。哦，那挺好的，我喜欢这个。所以，我的意思是，你有这样一种感觉：这个传统正在浮现，没有人确切知道它是如何产生的，但它与圣瓦伦丁的瞻礼日联系在一起，是的，然后瓦伦丁与所有这些……你知道的，你选择一个情人节伴侣并且它是浪漫的这种想法联系在了一起。嗯，你看，在这一点上，它确实相当浪漫，而且它并不商业化，对吧？没有……因为怎么可能呢，因为当时根本不存在那种可以真正剥削它的商业化基础设施。我的意思是，那是真的，对吧？在这一点上它并不商业化，
true isn't it it's not commercialized at this point well unless you're the jeweler supplying the duke of york i suppose yes and i think that's probably the case into the 18th century tom because i know the georgians were very keen on valent, weren't they? Well, the only thing I've got about the Georgians is that by the 18th century, you're starting to get Catholics, and indeed, you know, Christians of all denominations, but particularly Catholics, who are starting to raise their eyebrows at what's going on. And it's, as far as I can tell, it's not a kind of, you know, a mocking philosoph or an atheist who points out, who tries to kind of draw this, you know, the idea that St. Valentine's Day is a mutation of the Lupercalia. It's actually Catholics who are doing it, who are opposed to the idea of Valentine's Day. That's very weird. Why would they be opposed to it?
嗯，除非你是供应约克公爵的那个珠宝商，我猜。是的，我想在18世纪情况大概也是如此，汤姆，因为我知道乔治王时代的英国人非常热衷于情人节，不是吗？嗯，关于乔治王时代我唯一知道的是，到了18世纪，你开始看到天主教徒，甚至包括各教派的基督徒，尤其是天主教徒，开始对正在发生的事情挑起眉毛。据我所知，这并不是某种嘲弄性的哲学家或无神论者指出的、试图借此说明圣瓦伦丁节是牧神节变种的做法。实际上是天主教徒在这样做，他们反对情人节的这种理念。这非常奇怪。他们为什么要反对呢？
Because they, maybe because they don't want to give ammunition to Protestants who think it's just flummery and stuff. So you've got Butler, say Butler as in Butler's Lives, you know, the great kind of compendium of saints' lives that gets written in the 18th century. And he says that to abolish the heathens' lewd superstition custom of boys drawing the names of girls in honour of their goddess Februta Juno on the 15th of this month several zealous pastors substituted the names of saints in billets given on this day but that's not going to catch on is it i mean that's no but it's not true but it's not true but it's he's trying to explain how it is that um valentine has become associated with romance and to do that he has to posit that there is a festival a pagan festival that didn't exist that is a match to the idea of people you know kind of choosing one another's valentines so the whole thing is kind of structured but it's it's
因为他们，也许是因为他们不想给新教徒提供弹药，让新教徒觉得这不过是些无聊的迷信和杂耍。所以你看巴特勒（Butler）——也就是写《巴特勒圣徒传》（Butler's Lives）、那部在18世纪编写的伟大圣徒传记合集的那个巴特勒——他说：“为了废除异教徒那淫荡的迷信习俗——即男孩们在这15日这天为了纪念他们的女神布鲁塔·朱诺（Februta Juno）而抽签决定女孩名字的习俗——一些狂热的牧师用卡片上写着的圣人的名字取代了它们。”但这根本行不通，对吧？我的意思是，那——不，但这不是真的。但这不是真的，不过他在试图解释情人节是如何与浪漫联系在一起的，为了做到这一点，他不得不假设存在一个并不存在的、与人们互相选择情人节伴侣的理念相匹配的异教节日。所以整件事情在某种程度上是被构建出来的，但它
basically expressive of the fact that we we don't know really what the origins of this but in a way it doesn't really matter does it because by the mid-18th century it's become embedded in the kind and kind of folk tradition you know the 14th by this point everybody knows that the 14th of february is valentine's day there's a brilliant website called all things georgian which has a whole list of things that happened on valentine's day in the georgian period from newspapers so this is from reed's weekly journal the 16th of february 1751 it says thursday one m Mann, aged upwards of 60, who keeps a cook and chandler's shop in Shoreditch,
基本上反映了一个事实：我们其实并不知道这背后的起源是什么。但在某种程度上，这其实并不重要，对吧？因为到了18世纪中叶，它已经融入了某种民间传统之中。你知道，到了14世纪，此时每个人都知道2月14日是情人节。有一个绝妙的网站叫“一切皆乔治时代”（All Things Georgian），上面整理了乔治王时代报纸上报道的情人节发生的各种事情。这是摘自1751年2月16日的《里德周报》（Reed's Weekly Journal）：它说：“周四，肖尔迪奇（Shoreditch）一位年逾六十、经营熟食店和杂货店的曼夫人（Mann），嫁给了一位在该附近当兵、年约二十二岁的士兵。”这年龄差距挺大的。当邻居问她怎么能在这样的年纪考虑结婚时，她回答说今天是情人节，她下定决心要成双成对。现在你可能会想，这对那个士兵有什么好处？
was married to a soldier caught in that neighbourhood, aged about 22. That's quite a big age gap. Being asked by a neighbour, how could she think of marriage at these years? She replied it was Valentine's Day and she was resolved to be coupled. Now you might think, what's in it for the soldier?
我的意思是，没有多少22岁的年轻小伙子想娶60岁的老妇人。而答案就在下一行：“这位老妇人通过自己的节俭和勤劳，积攒了两百多英镑，她把这些钱毫无保留地赐予了她的新爱人。”这太浪漫了。多么浪漫的故事啊。
I mean, there's not many 22-year-old young men who want to marry 60-year-old women. And the answer is in the next line. The old gentleman had, by her frugality and industry, collected upwards of 200 pounds, which she freely bestowed on her new love. That is so romantic. What a romantic story.
这太浪漫了。我敢说这是一段结局美好的姻缘。但是汤姆，来自1784年《晨报》（Morning Herald）的这条怎么样？“值得一提的是，在上一个情人节，德比（Derby）圣彼得教堂有一对夫妇结婚了，他们两人加起来一共有七根大拇指，其中女的有三根，男的有四根。”哇。
That is so romantic. I bet that's a union that ended well. But how about this one, Tom, from 1784, from the Morning Herald. It may be worth remarking that on last Valentine's Day, a couple were married in St. Peter's Church Derby who had between them seven thumbs, vis the woman three and the man four. Wow.
这比安妮·博林（Anne Boleyn）还多。我的意思是，这可真够多的。这比你需要的拇指还要多。但这比安妮·博林还要多，是的，我的意思是这很多，这多得惊人，这比你需要的拇指还要多，但如果他们只是碰巧撞见彼此，那将是一个惊人的巧合。不过他们显然会有很多共同话题。不，他们肯定是在某个多拇指互助会上认识的。肯定是这样的。天哪，上面没说他们是怎么认识的吗？没有，没有。《晨报》的报道太糟糕了。这是最显而易见的问题。是的，但这是一种懒惰的新闻报道。
That's more than Anne Boleyn. Yeah. I mean, that's a heck of a lot. That's more thumbs than you need. But that's more than anne boleyn yeah i mean that's a lot that's a heck of a lot that's more thumbs than you need but that's an astonishing coincidence if they just happen to run into each other but they'd obviously have loads to talk about no but they must have met at some thumb support group it must be yeah goodness does it doesn't say how they met no it doesn't the morning herald is very poor reporting it's the obvious question yeah it's but it's it's lazy journalism
好吧，所以商业化的苗头已经出现了，我猜。嗯，事实是他们在报道它，而且他们还在不断报道它。而且我认为印刷术出现了，人们开始购买报纸。一旦人们开始购买东西，你就会拥有——所以，多米尼克。是的。在开场时，你宣读了那位被信件淹没的邮递员的精彩故事。是的。而且我一直期待着听到更多关于他收到的那些粗俗且冒犯的情人节卡片的内容。所以我们应该休息一下，然后再回到这个话题上来。不过在我们离开之前，到了19世纪，在教会内部，
okay so so it's um the hints of the commercial are there i guess well the fact that they're reporting it and then they're reporting it yeah and you've got print, I think, and people are buying it, newspapers. Once people are buying things, then you have. So, Dominic. Yeah. At the start, you read out that brilliant thing of the postman being engulfed by letters. Yes. And I've been looking forward to hearing more about the course and offensive Valentine's he got sent. So we should have a break and come back to that. But just before we go, by the 19th century in the church,
情人节作为浪漫与爱之日的理念开始被整合进去了。所以你知道罗马哪个教堂里藏有圣瓦伦丁的头骨吗？罗马的教堂之一。嗯，其中的一个瓦伦丁。是的，完全正确。但你知道其他的遗物都在哪里吗？剩下的遗物？不，它们毫无疑问在威尔特郡吧？不，它们在都柏林。哦，是的，它们在……嗯，它们在白修士街的圣母玛利亚卡尔梅利特教堂（Church of Our Lady of Mount Carmel, Whitefriar Street）。为什么它们会停留在那里？我来告诉你。
the idea of Valentine's Day as a day for romance and love is starting to be integrated. So do you know where the skull of a Valentine is in Rome? One of the churches in Rome. Well, one of the Valentines. Yeah, exactly. But do you know where the rest of them are the rest of the relics no uh they're in wiltshire no doubt no they're in dublin are they yeah they're in the um they're in the church of our lady of mount carmel white friar street why are they there i'll tell
当时有一位非常著名的爱尔兰加尔默罗会（Carmelite）传教士，名叫约翰·斯普拉特（John Spratt）。对。他去了罗马并发表了一场布道，一篇讲道词。那场讲道非常非常受欢迎。教皇似乎也听到了。因此，教皇将瓦伦丁的遗物作为感激的象征，送给了都柏林的那座加尔默罗会教堂。这真仁慈。所以有一张小纸条，随附了一张小纸条。
you there was a very famous irish carmelite preacher called John Spratt. Right. And he went to Rome and he gave a sermon, a homily. And it was very, very much appreciated. And the Pope seems to have heard it. And so he sent the relics of Valentine to the Carmelite church in Dublin as a token of his appreciation. That's kind. And so there's a little note, came with a little note.
你知道，当时有一位非常著名的爱尔兰加尔默罗会传教士叫约翰·斯普拉特。对。他去了罗马，并做了一场布道、一篇讲道。大家非常非常欣赏。教皇似乎也听到了。因此，他把圣瓦伦丁的圣物送到了都柏林的加尔默罗会教堂，以表示他的感激之情。真好。所以有个小纸条，随附了一张小纸条。
It was taken out of the cemetery of St. Hippolytus in the Tiburtine Way and it arrived in Dublin on the 10th of December, 1836. And if you go there now, it's very moving. There's a kind of statue of Valentine looking kind of rosy-cheeked.
它于1836年12月10日从台伯河畔的圣希波吕托斯公墓被移出，并运抵都柏林。如果你现在去那里，会觉得非常感人。那里有一个圣瓦伦丁的雕像，看起来面色红润。
Yeah. Rosy-cheeked and pink-lipped. So he's sort of turned into Cupid, I imagine. Has he? He has a slight hint of Cupid, the statue, yes. But there's a book there, and people can write if they're unhappy in love or if they're looking for love.
对。面色红润，嘴唇粉红。所以我想他有点变成丘比特了，是吗？那座雕像确实带有一点丘比特的影子。但那里有一本书，如果人们在爱情中不顺或者正在寻找爱情，可以在上面留言。
Oh, Lonely Hearts. Yeah, a kind of spiritual Lonely Hearts book. And it's very touching. So I saw it on my last trip to Dublin when we were we had a compendium of unexpected things in Dublin right and the relics of Saint Valentine were quite high on that list so we went to see them that sounds that sounds very romantic Tom yeah and not at all so not at all coarse and inoffensive which is what I hope no so we're striking after the after the break.
哦，寻缘。对，一种精神上的寻缘书。这真的很感人。所以我上次去都柏林时看到了它，当时我们在都柏林搜集各种意想不到的事物，对吧？圣瓦伦丁的圣物在这个清单上排得很靠前，所以我们去看了它们。听起来，听起来非常浪漫，汤姆，而且一点也不粗俗，一点也不冒犯，这正是我希望的。所以，我们在休息之后继续。
Can't wait. See you in a minute. Okay, bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
等不及了。一会见。好的，拜拜。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to our Valentine's Day edition of The Rest Is History. And excitement is rising because Dominic is about to tell us about the great Victorian tradition of coarse and offensive Valentines.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到我们《历史即全部》的情人节特辑。大家的情绪都高涨起来了，因为多米尼克即将为我们讲述维多利亚时代关于粗俗且冒犯性情人节卡片的伟大传统。
Well, you just have to wait a little bit longer for the coarse and offensive messages because I want to build up to them. Because we talked about how Valentine's Day had become sort of embedded in the Georgian imagination in the 18th century. And it's in Georgian Britain, I think in the second half of the century that you start to get pre-printed cards. So the ancestors of Valentine's cards. So if you think Valentine's cards were invented by American manufacturers, you are quite wrong. The Americans got the idea from us, from the British. And so first of all, people, Tom, have you ever handmade a Valentine's card? No. No, neither have I. Well, we're very poor compared with our Georgian predecessors
好吧，关于那些粗俗和冒犯性的信息，你们还得再等一会儿，因为我想为它们做个铺垫。我们之前讨论过情人节是如何在18世纪的乔治王时代融入人们的想象中的。我认为正是在乔治王时代的英国（大约在世纪后半叶），开始出现预先印制的卡片。也就是情人节卡片的鼻祖。所以，如果你以为情人节卡片是美国制造商发明的，那就大错特错了。美国人是从我们英国人这里得到这个创意的。首先，汤姆，你亲手制作过情人节卡片吗？没有。没有，我也没有。好吧，跟我们的乔治王时代的先辈相比，我们可真是太逊了。
because they would handmake them. People started to make what they called mechanical Valentines, which were kind of mass-produced printed ones. I think the first example of a surviving one is in York, York Castle Museum, and it was sent by katherine moss day to a mr brown of london and it's decorated with pictures of cupid so we talked about cupid what's mechanical about it was made by a machine it's printed oh i see i was kind of imagining a moving one no kind of like a box the kind of heart leaps out at you yeah a spring. No, no, no. It's just a nice message.
因为他们会亲手制作。人们开始制作他们所谓的机械情人节卡片，这是一种批量生产的印刷品。我想现存最早的例子在约克，约克斯城堡博物馆里，它是由凯瑟琳·莫斯·戴（Katherine Moss Day）寄给伦敦布朗先生（Mr. Brown）的，上面装饰着丘比特的图片——所以我们之前聊到了丘比特。它“机械”的地方在于它是机器制造的，是印刷出来的。哦，我明白了！我之前还以为是会动的呢。不，它有点像那种盒子，心会突然跳出来的那种，对吧？带弹簧的。不，不，不。它只是一条温馨的信息。
Since on this ever happy day, all nature's full of love and play, yet harmless still, if my design, tis but to be your Valentine. That's beautiful. It's nice, isn't it? I'm going to be reading a lot of poems in this second half, so be warned. And there's actually, in the same year, 1797, somebody publishes a book called The Young Man's Valentine Writer. So a manual about how to write nice Valentine poems.
既然在这个永远快乐的日子里，大自然充满了爱与嬉戏，然而它依然无害，如果我的心意只是想成为你的情人。这太美了。很温馨，对吧？在这后半部分我要读很多诗，所以请大家做好心理准备。事实上，就在同一年，即1797年，有人出版了一本名为《青年情人作家》（The Young Man's Valentine Writer）的书。这是一本关于如何撰写温馨情人节诗歌的手册。
So this sort of becomes more and more popular. And people basically, they're not sealing them in envelopes, they're not cards, they're sort of pieces of paper that you fold over. And they'll have lace on and threads and they'll be very sort of pretty but the big turning point tom you know i have a weird interest it will not an interest in but a knowledge of the history of the post office i do dominic i commend to the public my own audio book on the history of the post office called the people's post very good very good radio 4 series which you can buy uh at all good audio book retailers can you so you can yeah you can well yeah all good audiobook retailers. Can you? You can. Yeah, you can.
所以这种形式变得越来越受欢迎。人们基本上不把它们封在信封里，它们也不是卡片，而是那种对折的纸张。上面会有蕾丝和线，看起来非常漂亮。但是，汤姆，重大的转折点来了，你知道我对邮局历史有一种奇怪的兴趣——或者说不是兴趣，而是有所了解。我知道，多米尼克，我向公众推荐我自己的有声书，关于邮局历史的，名叫《人民的邮局》（The People's Post）。非常好，非常棒的BBC第四台系列节目，你可以在各大优质有声书零售商处购买。是吗？所以你可以——是的，你可以，所有的优质有声书零售商处。真的吗？可以的。是的，可以。
Is it? Wow. Yeah. I've probably got the best reviews of anything I've ever done, basically because I was merely the front man. Wow. I must have listened to it. And actual experts did all the work.
是吗？哇。是的。这可能是我做过评价最高的东西了，基本上是因为我只是个出面的人。哇。我一定得听听。真正的专家们完成了所有的工作。
I thought I'd kept abreast of all your oeuvre, but who you are. No, sadly not. So there are tens of thousands of Valentine's cards being sent in Britain, supposedly in the 1830s. But the real turning point is in 1840 when you have for the first time the penny post so before then tom if you sent a letter the recipient had to pay for it so um the penny post is this great revolution by this postal reformer called roland hill and the innovation is you pay a penny so it's democratizing communications and encouraging literacy and so on you pay a penny and you can send a letter anywhere and the recipient doesn't have to
我以为我已经掌握了你的所有作品，但你是谁……不，很遗憾没有。因此，在1830年代，英国寄出的情人节卡片多达数万张。但真正的转折点是在1840年，当时首次引入了便士邮政（penny post）。在此之前，汤姆，如果你寄一封信，收件人必须支付邮资。所以，便士邮政是由一位名叫罗兰·希尔（Rowland Hill）的邮政改革家发起的一项伟大革命，它的创新之处在于你只需支付一便士，这就使通信民主化并促进了识字率等等。你付一便士就可以把信寄到任何地方，而收件人完全不需要
pay for it at all. So it's the penny post in 1840 that gives you basically stamps. It gives us letterboxes and doors. There weren't letterboxes before because you would knock on the door to get the recipient to pay you. And it also creates pillar boxes. So it's designed, of course, by Anthony Trollope, the novelist. Yeah, the ancestor of Al Murray.
支付任何费用。因此，1840年的便士邮政基本上带来了邮票。它给我们带来了信箱和门。在此之前并没有信箱，因为你必须敲门让收件人付邮资。它还创造了邮筒（pillar boxes）。当然，它是小说家安东尼·特罗洛普（Anthony Trollope）设计的。是的，阿尔·穆雷（Al Murray）的祖先。
So what happens with all this is that letter writing becomes anonymous. You can post your letter. You don't have to hand your letter in and all that. So the possibility for the anonymous Valentine's card, where the recipient doesn't have to pay for, so they get they get it as it were for free um starts to become so this sort of spreads in the mid-19th century so blackwoods magazine says the post office system offers a facility for clandestine correspondence which
这一切带来的结果是，写信变得匿名了。你可以寄信，不必亲自交信等等。因此，匿名情人节卡片成为可能，收件人不需要付邮资，他们可以免费收到卡片……这种风气在19世纪中期开始蔓延。《布莱克伍德杂志》（Blackwoods Magazine）曾说：“邮政系统提供了一种秘密通信的便利，大西洋欧洲一侧任何一位体面的父亲或母亲想一想都会不寒而栗。”所以我们觉得这非常具有道德恐慌的意味，有点像今天的互联网。加尔文·埃斯特顿（GK Chesterton）曾谈到过邮箱，他说：“邮箱是一千个秘密的宝库，一千个灵魂的要塞。”所以这种观点认为，邮局已经成为秘密浪漫的某种管道。事实确实如此，因为在1840年代之后的几年里，情书和显然的情人节卡片迎来了巨大的繁荣。汤姆，你知道如果你对某人一见钟情，该怎么写信吗？你需要一本教你说什么的情书编写手册吗？
no respectable father or mother on the european side of the atlantic would think of without a shudder so we think this is very kind of moral panic like it is a bit more on the internet yeah you know gk chesterton said about post boxes he said the post box is the treasure house of a thousand secrets the fortress of a thousand souls so this sort of idea that the post office has become this sort of conduit for clandestine romance. And it's true because there's this huge boom in love letters and obviously Valentine's cards in the years after the 1840s. So do you know, Tom, do you know how you would write to somebody if you fell in love with them at first sight? Do you want a letter writing manual to tell you what to say?
我猜是写一首诗吧。不。亲爱的霍利小姐（Miss Hawley）：我深信你会原谅这封唐突且直白的信。尽管我们只相聚过一次，但为了打破礼节的束缚，我情不自禁地写信给你。爱有时生长缓慢，但有时它会在一瞬间迸发。昨晚离开你时，我的心已不再属于我自己。我当然不敢奢望在你心中留下什么印象，但你能否网开一面，容许我与你相识呢？这段话出自托马斯·希尔（Thomas Hill）的书……
To write a poem, I guess. No. Dear Miss Hawley, youley you will i trust forgive this abrupt and plainly spoken letter although i've been in your company but once i cannot forbear writing to you in defiance of the rules of etiquette affection is sometimes of slow growth but sometimes it springs up in a moment i left you last night with my heart no longer my own i cannot of course hope that i've created any interest in you but will you do me the great favor to allow me to cultivate your acquaintance? So that's from Thomas Hill's book of...
好吧，我觉得这不对。我的意思是，我并不是想贬低托马斯·希尔，但我会写一首诗。你知道霍利小姐是怎么回信的吗？他在书中给出了霍利小姐的回信范例。先生：考虑到我们直到昨晚才见面，你的便纸条让我感到意外。她听起来真有女人味。而且我们的对话仅限于平常的话题。
Okay, I think that's wrong. I mean, I don't want to diss Thomas Hill, but I would write a poem. Do you know what Miss Hawley writes back? He gives an example in Miss Hawley's reply. Sir, your note was a surprise to me, considering that we'd never met until last evening. She sounds so feminine. And that our conversation had only been on commonplace subjects.
你的行为确实相当奇怪。请你以后不要再提出这样的请求，并以此信作为我们通信的终点。是的，完全正确。所以你是对的。我是对的。是的。总之，人们开始，
Your conduct is indeed quite strange. You will please be so kind as to apply to me by not repeating the request, allowing this note to close that correspondence. Yeah, exactly. So you are vindicated. I am vindicated. Yeah. So anyway, people start, you know,
因为他们基本上不敢相信自己能写出诗来（你知道的），也懒得从情书手册里抄写这些段落。他们开始购买印刷的情人节卡片。而印刷情人节卡片之王是一个名叫乔纳森·金（Jonathan King）的人，他是伦敦的一位文具商，是晚期维多利亚时代的文具商。伦敦博物馆有一个藏品系列。你应该去参观一下。他们有1700种不同的卡片，
because they basically can't trust themselves to write poems and, you know, they can't be bothered to copy out these passages from kind of love letter manuals. They buy printed Valentine's cards. And the king of the printed Valentine's card is a man called Jonathan King, who's a stationer in London, late Victorian stationer. And there's a collection in the Museum of London. You should go to one of your walks. They have 1,700 different cards,
都是乔纳森·金制作的卡片样本。它们通常非常非常精致。这里有一个卡片上信息的极好例子。汤姆，这张卡片是用人类头发制作的，这是一种荷尔蒙。什么头发？人类头发。这里只写了人类头发。
examples of cards that Jonathan King made. They're often very, very fancy. Here's a good example of a card, of a message in a card. Tom, the card is made out of human hair, which is a hormone. What kind of hair? Human hair. All it says here is human hair.
从哪来的？人类头发？这里只写了人类头发制作的……从哪来的？人类头发。好吧，你知道卡罗琳·兰姆（Caroline Lamb）是如何向拜伦勋爵表达爱意的。我当然知道。但我敢打赌她没有把它做成胡子，而这张卡片……好吧。没有什么比用女士的阴毛做成胡子更能表达爱意了。好吧，我想你在脑海中想象了那卡片的前半部分，汤姆。但是带有胡子的那张卡片上有一条信息，上面写着：“致新时代女性，伴随着圣瓦伦丁最热烈的问候以及最好的期望，祝愿她能收到另一副附带男人的胡子。”哦，我明白了，是男人把胡子寄给女人。
From where? Human hair? All it says here is human hair fashioned into... From where? Human hair. Well, you know how Caroline Lamb expressed her devotion to Lord Byron. I do, indeed. But I bet she didn't fashion it into a moustache, which is what this card... Okay. Nothing says love. Like a lady's pubic hair fashioned into a moustache well i think you're imagining that first bit of that tom but the card that the moustache comes with a message that says for the new woman with saint valentine's heartiest greetings and best hopes she will receive another moustache with the man attached oh i see it's the man sending the moustache to the woman
是的，是的，完全正确。好吧，其实在这个时候，英国在情人节卡片方面绝对领先世界。太自豪了。美国的出版商和文具商会发布目录，上面列出了他们进口的英国情人节卡片。我翻出了一份1847年的目录，上面的分类简直精彩绝伦。搞笑的、多愁善感的、害相思病的、藏头的、滑稽的、讽刺剧式的、机智的、阿拉伯式的……它不断地列出所有的分类，最后还写着：令人兴奋的、心如刀割的、绝望的、狂乱发疯的、夺命的、浮夸的、讽刺的、浪漫的、求婚的、结婚的、妻管严的、自杀式的，以及许多其他种类。自杀式的，自杀式的，但是
yes yeah exactly okay so britain actually at this point absolutely led the world in Valentine's cards. So proud. And American publishers, American stationers would issue catalogues with lists of their imported British Valentine's cards. So I've dug one out from 1847 and the categories are absolutely splendid. Comic, sentimental, lovesick, acrostic, funny, burlesque,lesque witty arabesque it goes on and on listing all the categories and at the end it says enlivening heart aching despairing raving mad heart killing high flown lampooning romantic proposal espousal matrimonial henpecking suicidal and many other varieties suicidal suicidal but
马萨诸塞州伍斯特市有一位女士，我们的美国听众可能听说过，她叫埃丝特·豪兰（Esther Howland）。她基本上认为自己可以做得更好。好吧，她说：“所有这些进口的英国卡片都太贵了，美国有巨大的市场。”所以她创立了自己的生意。她压低了英国卡片的价格吗？她确实压低了，但我认为它们的质量非常好。她基本上是抄袭了英国情人节卡片的诗句。这是一个永恒的故事。并从德国等地进口原材料。它变成了一个庞大的帝国。我认为在半个世纪的时间里，直到它被1910年在堪萨斯城创立的霍 Hallmark 公司超越之前，她的公司基本上是美国最大的制造商。
there's a woman in uh worcester massachusetts who our american listeners may have heard of called esther howland and she basically decided that she could do better well she was she said they're too expensive all these imported british cars there's a huge market for it in america so she set up her own business did she undercut British? She did, but I think they were very good. She basically copied verses from English Valentines. It's a timeless story. And imported sort of materials from Germany and stuff. And it became a tremendous empire. And I think for half a century until it was actually overtaken by the Hallmark Company, which started up in Kansas City in 1910. Hers was basically the biggest sort of American manufacturer.
所以这完全是英国工业在面对美国和德国竞争时走向衰落的缩影。是的，我想是的。顺便说一句，汤姆，这些情人节卡片绝对太惊艳了。它们要好得多。它们精美得多。美国的那些？哦，19世纪的美国卡片和英国卡片。
So it's a complete metaphor for the decline of British industry in the face of American and German competition. Yes, I suppose it is. They were absolutely amazing, these Valentine's cards, by the way, Tom. They were far, far better. So they were much fancier. The American ones? Well, the Americans and the British ones of the 19th century.
人们狂热的巅峰期……我们在Discord和网上收到的许多问题都是：“这是一种20世纪的现象吗？它有点像万圣节吗？”我认为这正是英国人的普遍假设，即它基本上是一个浪漫版的万圣节，是一个商业化、美国化的传统。但实际上，我想说的是，大约在1840年到1880年之间，情人节比现在要盛大得多。当时是英国制造商的产品被美国人模仿。现在，你想要粗俗和冒犯性的内容。
The real peak of people, so many of the questions we had on Discord and online were, you know, is it a 20th century phenomenon? Is it sort of a Halloween? I think that's the assumption, isn't it, in Britain, that it's basically a romantic Halloween, a commercial Americanized tradition. But actually, Valentine's Day, I would say, was much bigger between about 1840 and 1880 than it is now. And it was British manufacturers being copied by Americans. Now, you wanted coarse and offensive.
是的，我想要。我们完全失去了联系的一个部分就是“醋味情人节卡片”（Vinegar Valentine）。关于这一点有一些精彩的研究，特别是布莱顿大学的一位学者安娜贝拉·波伦（Annabella Pollen），我应该感谢她，她写了许多关于这方面的文章。所以醋味情人节卡片是用来侮辱人的卡片，它们极其受欢迎。例如，上面会有一句说明文字。这里有一张卡片，上面的文字是：“八卦小姐”（Miss Nosy）。
Yes, I do. The one bit of this that we've completely lost touch with is the vinegar Valentine. And there's been some splendid studies of this that particularly there's a scholar called annabella pollen at the university of brighton who i should acknowledge she's written lots of articles and stuff about this so vinegar valentines were cards to insult people and they were exceedingly popular um so for example there's they would have a sort of caption on them so here's one that the caption says miss nosy
他会把它寄给他讨厌的女性，上面写着：“因为你到处八卦别人的私事，在大多数舞会上你只能坐着暖椅子。因为你对别人的事情如此‘热心’，你连一个朋友都没有。”多米尼克，这些是商业化生产的吗？是的，它们是商业化生产的，有成千上万张。你会走进WH Smith书店或者类似的地方——我是说同类商店——然后买一张醋味情人节卡片，把它寄给竞争对手播客，比如。所以，汤姆，我可能会把这个寄给你：“你是我希望遇到的最粗俗的恶棍，
and he would send it to a woman he disliked and it would says on account of your talk of others affairs at most dances you sit warming the chairs because of the care with which you attend to all others business you haven't a friend and dominic this would be commercially made or would yeah they're commercially made there are loads of them you'd'd go into WH Smiths or whatever, I mean, the equivalent, and you'd buy a vinegar valentine, you'd send it to rival podcasters, for example. So, for example, Tom, I might send you this. You're as vulgar a cad as I'd wish to meet,
然而你却被傲慢和自负吞噬。不过我想用不了多久，你就会发现所有人都认为你是个无知的乡巴佬。”天哪。我收到了这个。是的，我觉得那张……那张对你来说不太合适，这张好得多。正面只写着：“你是格蒂·加伯（Gertie Gabber）吗？”汤姆，你是格蒂·加伯吗？据我所知不是，不过——好吧，等等看。这就是诗里写的内容。“格蒂·加伯不知道她的唠叨会变得多么令人厌烦。她的舌头整天说个不停，却真的什么也没说。”
and yet you're devoured with pride and conceit. But I fancy before very long you'll find out that everyone thinks you're an ignorant lout. Goodness. I'm receiving that. Yeah, i'd feel actually that one that one is not uh that one is not appropriate for you this one is much better it just says on the front um are you gertie gabber are you gertie gabber tom not as far as i'm aware but well wait wait for it for it. So this is what the poem says. Gertie Gabber does not know her talking can quite tiresome grow. Her tongue keeps wagging all the day and really nothing does she say.
然后还有另一个叫做“炫耀狂”（Show Off）。显然这也不适合你。不。“炫耀狂。你声称自己什么都擅长。所以来吧，证明一下。让我看看你从屋顶跳下去有多厉害。”所以这些卡片开始时非常惊人，你可以在美国内战期间买到它们。士兵们会买这张卡片，正面写着，他们会把它交给他们的……
Then there's another one called Show Off. Obviously not appropriate for you at all. No. Show Off. You claim you're good at anything. So come on, show some proof. And let me see how good you are jumping off the roof so these were they started amazing so you can buy these yeah in the american civil war soldiers would buy this one it would say on the front and they would give it to their their
他们排里的外科医生什么的，正面会写着：“致外科医生，哈哈，老伤骨，你来啦。当叛军痛打我们时，你总是准备好你的器械来扯碎和砍伤我们。”你会在情人节把这些卡片寄给你讨厌的人。但我绝对最喜欢的一张卡片——我真的很希望有人能……把它带回来——卡片正面写着：“你是一个神经摧毁者。当一头猪被宰杀时，它发出的声音也比你的颤音和抖音要动听得多。后院猫咪在夜里的嚎叫，与你的歌声相比简直是一场美梦。你的尖叫和狂吼是如此折磨人的折磨，让人几乎希望自己
doctors in their this sort of surgeons in their platoon or whatever they would said on the front to the surgeon ho ho old sore bones here you come yes when the rebels whack us you're always ready with your traps to mangle sore and hack us and you would send these on valentine's day to people you disliked but my absolute favorite one of these which i really wish somebody would um bring back um the front of the card says you are a nerve destroyer when a pig's getting slaughtered the noise that it makes is sweeter by far than your trills and your shakes and the howling of cats in the backyard at night compared with your singings a dream of delight your squalls and your balls are such torture to hear a man almost wishes he
没有耳朵。如果有人能掐死你，从而结束他们的痛苦，他将获得你那些穷困潦倒、痛苦不堪的邻居们的由衷感谢。”哇。你逃不掉的。我认为这是顶级恶作剧，这就是……我的意思是，确实如此。而且这种东西能让许多人赚到钱。是的。
had not an ear if someone would choke you and thus end their pain, hearty thanks from your poor distressed neighbours he'd gain. Wow. You wouldn't get away. That's top trolling, I think, is the… I mean, it really is. And the idea that this is making lots of people money. Yeah.
我的意思是，这让今天的互联网看起来简直是良好行为的楷模。……比如《小妇人》、艾米丽·狄金森、罗伯特·勃朗宁等等。但实际上，人们在发送这些东西，太可怕了。关键是——匿名情人节卡片，对吧？没人知道，是的，完全正确。它们是没有署名的，你只会想：“天哪，我是格蒂·加伯吗？”不，或者——或者人们觉得我是格蒂·加伯。我一直在唱歌，我会说：“那不是真的，我不是。”但人们就是这么想的。好吧，就是这样，你以为自己一直在钢琴旁唱歌是为了给亲戚们带来快乐，日复一日地保持着维多利亚时代的风范，但实际上他们希望有人能掐死你。这很残酷，对吧？那么这个……这个习俗是什么时候开始消亡的呢？它似乎在……
I mean, it makes today's internet look an absolute model of good behavior. um sort of little women emily dickinson you know uh robert browning and so on but actually you know people are sending these but it's horrendous the key i mean anonymous valentine's day yeah yeah no one knows yes exactly they're unsigned and you just think god i'm gertie gabber well no yeah or or people think i'm gertie gabber yeah i've been singing i'd say that's not true i'm not but that's what people think well that's the thing you think you've been singing by the piano to entertain your relatives night after night in that sort of victorian way but actually they wish someone would choke you um it's harsh isn't it and when did this um when did this custom kind of fade it seems to have died out
19世纪末左右消亡了。我真的不知道，我觉得情人节本身在大约20世纪初普遍有所衰落。任何在听节目的富有创业精神的卡片制造商，是的，当然，这里存在市场空白。不过别寄给我们。不，不，市场上还有其他的历史播客。把卡片寄给他们，别寄给我们。所以我们还有其他内容，对吧？显然，情人节那天发生了一些事情。嗯，发生了一场大屠杀，对吧？
around the um end of the 19th century um i don't really know what i think there's a sort of diminution in valentine's day generally um right about the turn of the 20th century and i think any any entrepreneurial card manufacturers listening to this yeah of course there's a gap in the market don't send them to us though i mean no no the market. Don't send them to us, though. No, no. Other history podcasts are available. Send them to them, but not to us. So we've got some other stuff, haven't we? I mean, obviously, Valentine's Day, things have happened on Valentine's Day. Well, there's been a massacre, hasn't there?
我想他们对此有个问题。瘦子丹（Skinny Dan）。对。芝加哥的情人节大屠杀需要提一下。不过这跟情人节没什么关系，对吧？也跟浪漫无关。没有什么比像阿尔·卡 Capone 那样在车库里扫射更能体现浪漫了。对，对。在车库里枪杀人们。对那些不知道的人来说，情人节大屠杀是……
So I think they've got a question on that. Skinny Dan. Yeah. The St. Valentine's Day massacre in Chicago needs a mention. It's got nothing to do with Valentine, though, has it? Or romance. Nothing says romance like gunning down like al capone yeah yeah gunning down people in garages some valentine's day massacre for those people who don't know is a um it's the shooting of seven men
1929年2月14日星期四，在芝加哥北区林肯公园（L Park），有七名男子遭到枪击。这发生在禁酒令时期的尾声，当时芝加哥基本上变成了一个由两大帮派之间的帮派暴力撕裂的泥潭。其中一个是北区帮（North Side Gang），主要由爱尔兰人和波兰人组成；另一个被称为芝加哥黑帮（Chicago Outfit），由阿尔·卡 Capone 领导，他们是意大利人。
on thursday the 14th of february 1929 in uh l Park, Chicago, on the north side of Chicago. It comes towards the end of the Prohibition period, when Chicago has basically become a sort of a bit of a sink, riven by gang violence between two gangs. One of them is the North Side Gang, who are mainly Irish and Polish. And the other are what's called the Chicago Outfit, who are run by Al Capone. So they're Italians.
他们争斗的主要目标是酿酒和酒类分销。这两个帮派曾试图讲和但失败了。莫兰（Moran）曾派人去试图刺杀卡 Capone。此时卡 Capone 已经花了很多时间在佛罗里达州。他可以说是那种明星般的黑帮分子。我想，他是第一位真正的明星黑帮分子。基本上，在这个星期四早晨，他的一些手下伪装成警官，
And they're fighting mainly over the brewing and liquor distribution. The two gangs had tried to make peace but failed. Moran had sent people to go and try and kill Capone. Capone's actually spent a lot of time in Florida by now. He's that sort of gangster as celebrity. The first real gangster as celebrity, I suppose. But basically, this Thursday morning, some of his men disguise themselves as police officers.
闯入北区的一个车库，莫兰的一些手下在那里。里面还有两个旁观者。有五个莫兰的手下和两个旁观者。他们是一个验光师和一个机械师，不幸被卷入其中。黑帮分子让他们靠墙站成一排，然后用机枪扫射。
They go into a kind of garage on the north side where some of Moran's men are. There are also two kind of bystanders. There are five of Moran's men and two bystanders. They're kind of an optician and a mechanic who are sort of caught up in the sweep and they basically line them up against a wall and machine gun them.
他们都死了吗？都死了。奇怪的是……连那个可怜的验光师也死了？嗯，验光师与莫兰帮有某种模糊的联系，机械师也是。他们与其说是核心成员，不如说是随从。但他们都被杀害了。
And they all die? They all die. And the weird thing is... So even the poor optician? Well, the optician was sort of vaguely associated with the Moran gang, as was the mechanic. They were sort of hangers-on rather than full-on kind of. But they were killed.
作为一个验光师，年纪好像有点大了吧？验光师也是人嘛。机械师还可以理解。对，但是，你知道，机械师你能看得见，但验光师……对，但也许如果你需要的话……你想跟黑帮混在一起。但如果你需要——如果你要当枪手，你需要好视力。
Seems old for an optician. Opticians are people too. You can kind of get a mechanic. Yeah, but, you know, mechanics you can see, but an optician. Yeah, but maybe if you need to be. You want to hang out with gangsters. But if you need, if you're going to be a gunman, you need good eyesight.
这倒也是。我的意思是。对，视力宝（Spec Savers）。所以其中……唯一一个在事件结束时还活着的人正在死去，他叫弗兰克·古森伯格（Frank Gusenberg）。他是北区帮的一个真正的暴徒。但是由于所谓的“沉默法则”（omerta）文化，你知道那种不能开口说话的规矩，当警察赶到时，警察对他说——他身上有14处枪伤——警察对他说：“谁开枪打的你？
That's true. I mean. Yeah, spec savers. So the one, one one of the only one of them is sort of really alive at the end of it so he's dying he's called frank guzenberg he was a he was a real hoodlum for the north side gang and uh but because of the sort of omerta cult you know the sort of you can't speak and when the police arrived the police said to him he's got 14 bullet wounds the police police say to him, who shot you?
谁开枪打的你？”他说：“没人开枪打我。”显然他已经中枪了。直到他死前的最后一刻，他都否认自己中枪。这简直是自欺欺人。令人印象深刻。但情人节大屠杀对汤姆来说非常重要，因为它是一桩特大丑闻。它促使联邦政府对卡 Capone 采取行动。众所周知，他们在1932年以逃税罪起诉了他，但这也间接
Who shot you? And he says, no one shot me. So obviously he has been shot. And he denies being shot, having been shot right up to the point where he dies. It seems absolutely self-defeating. Impressive. But the Valentine's Day massacre was very important to Tom because it was a very big scandal. It encouraged the federal government to move on capone obviously they charge him a tax evasion famously in 1932 but it helps to
导致了腐败且与卡 Capone 勾结的芝加哥市长威廉·威福·汤普森（William Hale Thompson）的倒台。你知道当他失势时《芝加哥论坛报》是怎么说的吗？不知道。“对于芝加哥来说，汤普森意味着污秽、腐败、猥亵、愚蠢、破产。他给我们的城市带来了国际声誉：白痴般的滑稽剧、野蛮的犯罪、盛气凌人的暴徒主义、无休止的贪污，以及沮丧的公民。他让芝加哥成了美国文明崩溃的代名词。”没有什么比这更能说明浪漫了，这种愚蠢的滑稽剧……难道……警察的介入在情人节大屠杀中受到怀疑，对吗？嗯，他们从来没有……实际上，嗯，当时有人伪装成警察，他们有警察的……
bring down the city's mayor william w thompson who was corrupt and was in league with the capone people do you know what the chicago tribune said when he fell from grace no for chicago thompson has meant filth corruption obscenity idiocy bankruptcy he's given our city an international reputation for moronic buffoonery barbaric crime triumphant hoodlumism unchecked graph graft and a dejected citizenship he made chicago a byword for the collapse of american civilization nothing says romance to me more than that's moronic buffoonery um isn't is it right that um uh the involvement of the police is suspected in the valentine's well they've never they've never actually well there were two there were people disguised as police and they had police
哦，原来是这样。但是，卡 Capone 和所有这些帮派与芝加哥警察以及芝加哥当局有着非常非常紧密的联系。所以，是的，在某种程度上，汤姆，当时的腐败如此严重，以至于黑帮和警察之间的界限几乎是模糊不清的。所以，是的，从某种意义上说你是对的。好吧，没有什么比在车库里枪杀别人更能体现浪漫了。所以还发生了其他事情。库克船长被杀了。他的确被杀了，是的。节目的老朋友。
oh okay that's what it is um but what i uh the capone all these gangs were very very tightly interwoven with the chic police and with the Chicago authorities. So actually, yes, in a way, Tom, there was such intense corruption that the dividing line between the gangsters and the police was virtually imperceptible. So yes, you're right in a way. Okay, so nothing says romance like
格里高利七世（Gregory VII），我最喜欢的教皇。他在这一天将亨利四世（Henry IV）逐出教会。哦天哪，你最喜欢这个故事了。
gulling down people in a garage. So other things happened. Captain Cook was killed. He was indeed, yes. Friend of the show. Gregory VII, my favourite Pope. He excommunicated Henry IV on this day. Oh God, you love that story.
我确实很喜欢。好吧，我们以后会做一集关于这个节目的。所以这是11世纪。是的。亨利四世是皇帝。格里高利七世是教皇。他们本该相处融洽，但并没有。
I do. Well, we're going to do an episode on that at some point. So this is the 11th century. Yeah. Henry IV is the Emperor. Gregory VII is the Pope. They're meant to get on. They don Yeah. Henry IV is the emperor. Gregory VII is the pope. They're meant to get on. They don't.
亨利四世对格里高利七世说：“下台吧，下来，下来，放弃你的教皇职位。”作为回应，格里高利将他逐出教会。就在他这么做的时候，教皇的宝座裂成了两半。哇。你可以试试。多米尼克，我觉得这事没真的发生过。哦，好吧。我觉得这事没真的发生过。这在本播客中真是屡见不鲜。
Henry IV says to Gregory VII, step down, come down, come down, give up your papacy, to which Gregory responds by excommunicating him. And as he does so, the papal throne splits in two. Wow. You can try that. Dominic, I don't think it really happened. Oh, okay. I don't think it really happened. That's so often the case on this podcast. Dominic, I don't think it really happened. Oh, okay. I don't think it really happened.
我知道，我知道。但最近的一件事，当然是发生在我们的有生之年，就是霍梅尼（Ayatollah Khomeini）对萨尔曼·鲁西迪（Salman Rushdie）下达了追杀令。那简直是一种充满醋味的醋味情人节卡片。那确实是一张醋味情人节卡片，对吧？可惜他没用押韵的方式写出来。我不该
That's so often the case on this podcast. I know, I know. But the most recent thing, of course, that happened within our lifetimes was the issuing of the fatwa against Salman Rushdie by the Ayatollah Khomeini. That's kind of vinegar Valentine of a very vinegary. That really is a vinegar Valentine, isn't it? Shame he didn't do it in rhymes. I shouldn't
笑，但是，如果他用维多利亚时代的风格写的话……“我多么痛恨《撒旦诗篇》，有坏书，还有更坏的书。”是的。如果萨尔曼·鲁西迪在听这个节目，向他道歉。所以这显然是一件大事。
laugh, but yeah, if he'd written it in a sort of Victorian style. How I hate the satanic verses. There are bad books and there are worse's. Yes. Apologies to Salman Rushdie if he's listening to this. So that was obviously
不管怎样，我想这就是情人节的大部分内容了，对吧？我想我们一直在为这个做铺垫，不是吗？当我刚开始做这个播客时，我真的很想达到这样一个地步，那就是我们可以发布快速通道……用韵文说话。我的意思是，我愿意把这看作一张送给听众的情人节卡片。是的，确实如此，汤姆。既然你这么说了，我想我们应该以另一张送给听众的情人节卡片来结束。是的，确实如此，汤姆。既然你这么说了，
a big deal. Anyway, so I think that's pretty much Valentine's Day, isn't it? I think we've been sort of building up to that, haven't we? When I first started doing this podcast, I really wanted to get to the point where we would be issuing fast pass. Speaking in verse. I mean, I like to think of this as a Valentine's Day card to our listeners. Yes, it is, Tom, actually. And since you've said that, I think we should end with another Valentine's Day card to our listeners. Yes, it is, Tom, actually. And since you've said that,
我想我们应该以另一条情人节寄语来结束。这是一条真正的维多利亚时代的情人节寄语。也许并不适合我们所有的听众，但可能适合其中的一两位。“瓶子的亲吻是你内心的欢乐，每晚醉醺醺地回到床上。你在乎什么少女，无论她多么白皙？除了你的美酒，你没有多余的爱。再见。”你在乎什么少女，无论她多么白皙？除了你的美酒，
I think we should end with another Valentine's message. This is a genuine Victorian Valentine's message. Maybe not appropriate for all our listeners, but for one or two, perhaps. The kiss of a bottle is your heart's delight and fuddled you real home to bed every night. What care you for damsels, no matter how fair? Apart from your liquor, you've no love to spare. Goodbye. What care you for damsels, no matter how fair, apart from your liquor,
你没有多余的爱。再见。情人节快乐。感谢收听《历史即全部》。如需收听加更节目、抢先收听无广告版本以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册，网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐即全部》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的娱乐圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的特权，
you've no love to spare. Goodbye. Happy Valentine's Day. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest is history pod.com i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
访问 therestisentertainment.com。也就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。